women go on Tik Tok and they ask men how
often they think of the Roman Empire and
it has exploded in popularity I don't
even know how this is a thing I never
think of the Roman Empire I never have I
never think about it I I don't do you
think about it yeah it was weird when I
was asked this question in the office
because I didn't know about the Tik Tok
thing and they're like hey Jason how
often do you think about the Roman
Empire I was like you know I bet a
couple times a week looking at really
yeah couple times a week that's a lot I
know you know it's New York reminds me
of Rome I think about the end of the
Roman Empire and if we're facing that I
don't know it's on my mind all right the
Roman Empire hashtag has listen to this
1.5 billion views you realize all the
years I don't know what people are into
neither do I all the years I was on the
radio I should have just talked about
the Roman Empire yeah you should have
asked everybody who called how often do
you think about the Roman Empire this is
the weirdest thing to me the trend is uh
eating and discussing canned fish
sardines an chovies you know who's
eating sardines is a JD he likes it JD
enjoys canned baby sardines from Tik
Tock DD hey JD what's with you and the
sardines you always such a picky eater
I'm surprised you're branching out into
sardines well I was we I was out I was
out blit of course he had some sardines
we were having champagne or whatever he
opened the thing of sardines and I tried
them they were good they were all right
they actually opened a huge sardine
store right down the block from uh the
studio it's it's just all they do is
sell sardines and I bought the most
expensive sardines in there just in case
we were I was wondering what like an
expensive sardine is well why don't we
put up a video of you eating sardines
the lady at the store told me that these
were hand deboned and hand skinned from
Portugal $40 sardines show I don't want
my sardines handled by
anyone oh here they go they got it
already we doing this now you want do
this now all right JD start the talk
about how you're opening the can all
right so first you didn't even show us
show the can hold on you guys are
talking what the hell okay all right
we'll be quiet you do it we're not
saying a word go so this is
sardin uh SE SE ESP I don't know what
the hell this says skinless and boneless
sardines and olive oil taking the spoon
inside boy they got them packed in here
good
God talk about how it's a $40 can of
sardines you just dropped oil all over
the floor why I don't want to I'm sorry
you should get a plate or somebody
should have given him a plate here we go
here we go no this is a great video
don't leave him alone leave them alone
don't stop helping this is going to go
viral go the messy sardine e so I have a
sardine on the spoon it's in the olive
oil I'm going to eat it right
now little
dry no it's okay it's all right
it's I'm kind of like a tuna fish or
whatever I don't need a chip don't worry
about a
chip all right we got another uh
wow
H okay good it's all right good very
very
salty are we going to eat the whole can
I'm not eating the whole can I'm not
eating the whole can all right all right
all right that's enough I just want to
uh cover all our bases JD how often do
you think about the Roman
Empire I don't think about it at all
actually we created something new today
JD talking about the Roman Empire while
he's eating
sardines